CNN'S ALEXANDRA FIELD HAS MORE
IN THIS WEEK'S "BEYOND THE CALL
OF DUTY."
>> EVERYTHING THAT YOU SEE AND
HEAR IN THIS TRAILER IS WHEN
THEY WILL BE SHIPPED TO UKRAINE.
I NEED MORE.
>> Reporter: TEN TONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN BOXED UP HERE IN
CLIFTON, NEW JERSEY.
THEY'RE EN ROUTE NOW TO THE WAR
ZONE.
THE PLAN IS TO ACCEPTED IT ALL
TO THE POLISH FIRE SERVICE,
WHICH WILL PASS IT OVER TO
UKRAINIAN FIREFIGHTERS.
THE COLLECTION, NOTHING SHORT OF
MONUMENT AL, WAS DONE BY THIS
MAN.
THREE YEARS AGO HE JOINED THE
CLIFTON, NEW JERSEY FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
>> SEEING THE BROTHERHOOD
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENTS, THAT
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS.
WHEN RUSSIA INVADED, HE KNEW HIS
UKRAINIAN BROTHERS NEEDED HIM
TOO.
>> YOU SEE THE BROTHERHOOD NOT
JUST IN THE UNITED STATES BUT
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, INCLUDING
OVERSEAS.
EVERYBODY COMES IN AT ONCE IN A
TIME OF NEED.
>>> WHAT STARTED AS AN EFFORT TO
COLLECT A FEW SETS OF GEAR
TURNED INTO 1,100 SETS AND SO
MUCH MORE.
>> WE WANTED TO FOCUS ON
FIREFIGHTERS PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
WHICH WOULD BE YOUR COAT, YOUR
PANTS, HOOD, HELMET, AND GLOVES
AND BOOTS.
THEN WE BRANCHED OUT JUST A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER AND TOLD
PEOPLE WE WOULD NEED HAND TOOLS.
THEN WE BRANCHED OUT TO THE
MEDICAL SIDE WITH BACK BOARDS.
>> MOSTLY RETIRED GEAR BUT
PERFECTLY USABLE, HAVE COME FROM
MORE THAN 100 FIRE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> WE WERE GETTING CONTACTED BY
DEPARTMENTS IN COLORADO AND
MINNESOTA AND WISCONSIN AND
OHIO.
THAT'S WHAT FIREMEN DO.
>> Reporter: THE DELIVERIES
HAVEN'T STOPPED.
ON
>> I AM UKRAINIAN.
SO WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS
THROUGH FACEBOOK, I BROUGHT IT
UP IN OUR MEETING, WE HAD SOME
GEAR THAT WE WERE GOING TO GET
RID OF ANYWAY, I SAID LET'S
DONATE IT, PUT IT TO A GOOD
CAUSE.
>> Reporter: ANOTHER TRUCKFUL
FROM HALIDON, NEW JERSEY.
>> WE BROUGHT BUNKER GEAR,
JACKET, HELMET, GLOVES, SOME
BOOTS.
GOT TO HELP OUT ONE ANOTHER.
>> Reporter: THE MONEY TO SEND
THE GEAR IS BEING RAISED BY A
NONPROFIT, NEW UKRAINIAN WAVE
PASSAIC, RELYING ON A GO FUND ME
PAGE.
THE SHIPMENTS WILL INCLUDE
UKRAINIAN FLAGS WITH THE
INSIGNIA OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
DONATED STITCHED ON THEM.
>> HOPEFULLY SOME DAY WE'LL FIND
THE PICTURES OF THE FLAG AND THE
GEAR MAKING IT TO THE FRONT
LINES WHERE THEY NEED IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reporter: WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
SAY TO THE PEOPLE WHO WILL WEAR
THIS GEAR?
>> THE PEOPLE WHO WEAR THE GEAR
BEFORE YOU, JUST K